okay so by now we all know the routine
of the quasi holiday known as Halloween
you stay home kids knocking at your door
they ask for candy and they take you for
all you're worth
forcing you to piss away a free night
staying inside and catering to the five
to 16 year old freeloaders of our
society for some reason we've adopted
this tradition in which it's okay for
adult strangers to dress in costumes to
give candy to kids yeah now we know why
Roman Polanski's trying to get back in
and this year Halloween falls on a
Saturday one of our two much-needed days
of rest I mean why couldn't the
Illuminati or the Rothschilds or Colonel
Sanders or whoever determines these
things do with Halloween what they did
with Thanksgiving and make it fall on
like every third Monday in October or
something and no one can chalk it up to
accuracy because wasn't Jesus born in
like April we celebrate his birthday in
December I mean that's a four-month epic
fail on the celebration of the birth of
the Messiah or eight depending on how
you look at it so come on surely we can
move Halloween to an already useless day
like Monday or something but since
that's just not going to happen we're
expected to sit home this Saturday and
give out candy well I say not this year
we are going to take this Saturday back
for ourselves
[Music]
so socially expected that you stay in on
Saturday and give out candy because if
you stay in on Saturday and don't give
out candy and just let the doorbell ring
or open the door and be like sorry I
don't have candy your neighbors are
going to shun you is the stain of a
cul-de-sac or the suburbs or wherever it
is that you live and if you decide to go
out and actually have a life on a
Saturday like people do then you're
branded the humbug dick of the
neighborhood in any case your conscience
is just going to eat at you because you
know your neighbors like kids don't look
at him don't go into his yard he's a
dick in any case it's safe to say that
we've been taught that we can't have our
cake and eat it too I say there's a way
for you to have your Saturday night and
maintain your neighborhood status quo
and all you need to dodge a wasted
Saturday night in is a candy bowl a
piece of paper a magic marker and scotch
tape and what comes next is pretty easy
you then take the marker and write take
one please on the piece of paper and
tape it to the candy bowl like so you
then put the empty labeled candy bowl
outside and that's it you're done simple
easy and damn near free to do it is now
your free Saturday night to do what you
want you do not have to stay inside and
give out candy any in every group that
comes to your door will see the empty
bowl with the note and think to
themselves damn kids
does this thing to some 16-year old
douchebag punk came three minutes before
them and shamelessly cleaned you out I
mean the absolute worst case scenario is
you enjoy your Saturday night and
maintain your status among the people of
the neighborhood but if you are really
lucky you get to martyr yourself among
your community as the person who put his
trust in the youth of America and got
burned then you go ahead and enjoy all
the free beer and food you get it the
next neighborhood barbecue and there's
no need to thank me it is what I do but
if you genuinely have no qualms about
what your neighbors think to you this is
still just kind of fun to do so there
you go go out on Saturday night and have
fun because in this economy you can't be
shelling out hard-earned money to create
gluttons of kids that you've never seen
before and will certainly never see
again you can take all that money you
would have spent on kids candy and go
buy something for yourself or buy
something for your chick or the bar
skank that keeps eyeballing you after
she's had seven shots of something that
looks like piss and then pay for the
doctor bill and she gives you the clap
okay it's more fun than getting a razor
blade in an apple
I think so I'm Jeremy and you have a
good Halloween I'm just glad I could
help